[Music]
you guys have been so smart about your
relationship having come off in the show
and you're engaged you are engaged but
like you said you still have to date
what made you no but yes this definitely
is the person I want to marry
I'm wasn't always great at change I grew
up in a very stable household and I had
a job for you know a long time and so
moving to a new city making new friends
I was really hard for me and going
through all those changes I'm seeing how
supportive Ben was and then especially
launching a blog and you know
experiencing you know diving in
headfirst into this whole new world that
I don't know a lot about seeing how much
support he has given me and how he
really has been my biggest true leader
my biggest fan
that was what made me feel like okay I
mean such a great decision she cares
about us as a couple and not just me as
a person not just her as a person she
really cares about us and that we're the
best and I think that's who I want to
share life with you know that's who I
want to be the mother of my kids
what are you guys's fears about marriage
I don't know if it's a fear but I'm
going to get married one time and I want
to make sure that I'm taking that very
seriously and just really crossing my
T's and dotting my eyes and making sure
that Ben knows okay make sure Ben knows
everything there is to know about me and
I know everything there is to know about
him you didn't committee your life to
somebody else right and so one thing
we're doing it's really cool it's today
is that your first day through our
church we were doing couples counseling
way before even premarital counseling so
we're gonna go today for our first
session as a couple and we're gonna
couples therapy
we need kind of an arm like a mediator
between us just to help us communicate
any things that we you know need to work
out individually together and then let's
celebrate
you know like Lauren makes my life
better it's life's good
you
[Music]